in black widow one of the villains that
natasha romanov fights is classic marvel
villain taskmaster
a skilled assassin who imitates others
fighting styles
tony masters is the identity of the
person underneath the skeletal looking
mask
in the marvel comics version of
taskmaster however the marvel cinematic
universe changes things
up a bit with the character's identity
for black widow
revealing after a lot of speculation
over the past few months
taskmaster to be someone from natasha's
past
spoiler alert the mcu taskmaster is none
other than antonia drakov
wait who that's a name that traces back
to the original
i've got red in my ledger conversation
natasha has with loki
aboard the shield helicarrier in the
first avengers film
[Music]
can you wipe out that much red
drakov's daughter drakop's daughter was
just a young girl
when she was caught in the explosion
that took place during nat's final
mission
to eliminate dracoff himself the
mastermind behind the red room
before joining shield when the mask
comes off
antonia presents a scarred and ruined
face to her rival
however as you might guess the person
who plays antonia is rather attractive
in real life
and you may have seen her before in her
previous work
the actress's name is olga kurilenko and
although she appears to be uncredited
in this film she is a ukrainian french
actress and model with one of
hollywood's most coveted roles for
gorgeous women on her resume
after several roles in french cinema and
television
krielenko's breakout role came in the
2007
cinematic adaptation of the popular
hitman video game
starring timothy oliphant in the title
role as assassin agent 47
the film revolves around his murder
missions for the organization
a shadowy group that trains young men to
be professional killers from a young age
he crosses paths with kirilenko's
character when he is sent
to publicly execute the russian
president
hitman managed a dreadful 16
critics score on rotten tomatoes but
grossed an impressive
99 million dollars against its 24
million dollar budget
it was due for a sequel in which
elephant did not plan to appear
but was instead rebooted in 2015's
hitman agent 47 with rupert friend in
the lead role
krielenko was not involved in the reboot
but the first film
served as an important stepping stone in
her career
a year after hitman was released
kurilenko became a bond girl
early in her acting career starring in
quantum of solace
opposite daniel craig in 2008. the
hollywood reporter stated in 2019 that
she
found her niche during that movie and
has been in contention for some of the
industry's most
action-oriented leading lady roles she
starred in oblivion with tom cruise in
2013
and was a runner-up to gal gadot for the
role of wonder woman
in the dc extended universe she also
starred in the courier from 2019 as an
ex-soldier who uses her combat skills
when the delivery goes awry
she's now been doing action films for 12
years and it all started with the
training she did for quantum of solace
kurilinko told the hollywood reporter i
remember coming home
collapsing on my bed and falling asleep
it was a big shock for my body
quantum was the start of all these
physical action films that i did after
but it was the very first one for which
i had trained so hard and so much
it was six months and so intense for the
first month
i trained literally every day from
morning till evening
i went from doing nothing to suddenly
doing everything that's super intense
she noted that regular gym workouts
never gave her endorphins
but martial arts or sparring do she's
clearly in the right line of work
her other films include to the wonder
with ben affleck and the dark comedy the
death of stalin
like a lot of celebs she made news in
2020 for catching the coronavirus
but it's fairly certain her fame from
this point forward will be for other
things
you're going to see this lovely face
again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one